hello everyone I am mank and welcome to
this video on how does a ransomware
attack works
in this video we will cover topics like
what is ransomware attack
how does a ransomware attack work types
of ransomware attacks effects of
ransomware on the business how to
prevent from the ransomware attack and
the last one is popular and somewhere
attacks and let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
Technologies if you are attacking on a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press that Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
as we know the demand for cyber security
person is skyrocketing so if you want to
master the field of cyber security then
simply Run's postgraduate program in
cyber security in collaboration with MIT
is clearly the right choice for you so
this postgraduate program in cyber
security is designed to equip you the
skills required to become an expert in
the rapidly growing field of the cyber
security this cyber security program
aims to help you to stay ahead of all
the latest cyber security Trends so key
features of this program is simply and
postgraduate program certificate master
classes from MIT faculty featuring
modules from MIT SSC and EC Council
access to ceh Kit 25 plus Hanson project
and many more this cyber security
certification program began with
introductory level skills and then
progress to the advanced cyber security
technique these programs cover all the
essential skills you will need to become
an expert in the field of cyber security
cyber security is one of the top concern
of the business today in an industry
from securing data to anticipating cyber
attacks and placing Enterprise wide
safeguards to prevent them employers
worldwide are increasingly looking for
qualified cyber security Professor to
join that so what are you waiting for
find the course link mentioned in the
description box below and enroll today
so let's get started in 2015 the Tesla
Crypt ransomware rapidly spread causing
significant disruption to numerous
Gamers following extending gaming
session Gamers were alarmed to find an
unfamiliar text file label Ransom note
on their desktop the content of this
Tech file is informed that the hacking
group had taken control of their game
files and private document encrypting
them in an unreadable format to regain
access to their valuable data each gamer
was required to pay a ransom of 500
worth of bitcoin to a specific Bitcoin
address upon payment they would receive
the master key necessary to decrypt
their files this was the Tesla Crypt
ransomware move on to their
understanding what exactly are answerver
attacks is all about so what is a
ransomware attack a ransomware attack
refers to a type of malware designed to
encrypt personal information and
document prompting the victim to pay our
rnsm in order to decrypt them this
payment is typically made using
cryptocurrency to maintain anonymity
although other payment methods may also
be utilized even after the money has
been sent there is no guarantee that the
hacker will send the decryption key or
unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situation victim makes the
payment hoping for the best so the
attackers bringing out the attacks
mainly the targeted renowned names of
any organization which leads to a lot of
damage and theft to a valuable
information so now let's understand how
such an attacks works so how does our
ransomware attacks work the first one is
the spread of ransomware only start with
phishing attacks a ransomware attack
gains access to a victim device through
infected emails messages and malicious
sites and encrypt the data in that
device the ransomware uses simple
asymmetric encryption algorithms blocks
a user's files and make them difficult
to decrypt without knowing the key and
the third one is it also Maps the
location for targeted file type that
include file stored locally and mapped
and unmapped network accessible devices
and the fourth one is it can also spread
wire malware transmitted via untrusted
application installation or even a
compromised wireless network and the
fifth one is ransaver adds instruction
files describing the pay for decryption
process then use uses those files to
present a ransom node to the user now
let's understand types of friend server
attacks so there are numerous types of
ransomware available but they mainly
fall into three categories the first one
is Locker ransomware it is a type of
malware that blocks standard computer
functions from being accessed until the
payment to the hacker is not complete it
shows a lock screen that doesn't allow
the victim to use the computer for
primary purposes and the second one is
crypto ransomware this transferware
encrypts the local files and documents
to computers once the file are encrypted
finding the decryption key is impossible
unless a ransomware version is ruled and
the keys are already available only and
the third one is scareware it is a fake
software that claims to have detected a
virus or other issue on your computer
and direct you to pay to resolve the
problem some scareware logs the computer
while other flood the screen with pop-up
alerts without damaging the files so
after seeing types of ransomware let's
move forward and see some effects of
ransomware on the businesses so the
impact on ransomware attacks on a
business can severally destructive as
per the report ransomware has inflicted
staggering cost of over 8 billion on
business in the past year so let's see
what are the reasons first one is data
loss businesses may suffer significant
data losses resulting in critical
information being inaccessible or
permanently destroyed the second one is
downtime and infrastructure compromise
ransomware compromise the business
infrastructure leading to disruptive
downtime periods and the third one is
costly recovery efforts the recovery
process after a ransomware attack can be
expensive the expensive might surprise
the actual Ransom amount and the fourth
one is customer loss The Fallout from a
con ransomware attack may lead to losing
customers who may seek Services
elsewhere so these effects highlight the
severity of ransomware attacks and
underscore the importance of robust
cyber security measure to safeguard
businesses against search thread so now
let's move forward and see how to
prevent the ransomware attacks so how
can one prevent ransomware attacks
Security Experts recommend the following
measures to protect against ransomware
threats so the first one is regularly
backup on Computing devices to ensure
data can be restored in case of any
attack and the second one is conduct an
inventory like of all assets to have a
comprehensive understanding of the
organization digital lens and the third
one is keep software including antivirus
programs up to date address known
vulnerabilities and the fourth one is
educate educate end users to avoid
clicking on links in emails or opening
emails attachment from unknown sources
so by implementing these messages
individuals and organization can enhance
their defense against ransomware and
mitigate potential risk effectively so
now let's move forward and see some
popular and somewhere attacks in history
so here are five most popular and
similar attacks that occurred in recent
year and grabbed the entire world's
attention the first one is Wanna Cry
foreign first emerged in 2017 and
infected thousands of computer in over
150 countries the second one is Patia
Patel and somewhere is an encrypting
malware that first surfaced in 2016 it
encapes critical files and hold them
hostile unless you pay and the third one
is server server appeared in 2016 that
spread through phishing emails and
encrypted users files and data with
Advanced encryption methods and the
fourth one is bad rapid bad rapid
ransomware is reported to be an improved
variant of the patial enzymeware it
locks up the victims computer servers
and the other files preventing them from
regarding access until are Ransom in the
form of Bitcoin is paid and the last one
is lucky released in 2016 log is a file
type of ransomware sent using emails
demanding payment through an invoice in
the form of tinted Microsoft Word
document containing infectious macro so
that's all we had for you in this video
we can call it a wrap now if you have
still any question or down let us know
in the comment section below and our
team of experts will help you at the
earliest thank you so much for being
here today we will see you next time
until then stay safe keep learning with
simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here